have you ever been star struck when you
when you're on the job
what do you mean by star struck i know
just as in like you
did enough vertical with like a voice
actor or actress that you
just loved before yeah like who's the
most like whoa person you've ever met
um
[Music]
whoa really yeah that's [ __ ] cool
yeah
i need a little context too old scar is
like
yeah a snake he did salt snakes oh okay
wow
like he's the kind he's the guy that he
has that really distinct like
talking style where he's like yeah i
can't i can't do an impression
oh my god he he's kind of like the
tournament yeah yeah it's it's like
yeah yeah yeah actually does a really
good like old stock
yeah yeah yeah he's just you know like
the soul of snakes
but he's probably like the top five yeah
like he's like a [ __ ] legend
yeah yeah does he mean a lot on twitter
can i follow him on twitter so i don't
know i feel like he does right
no i know i know the english voice stuff
david david hater i know david
i could love them i feel that yeah again
like i feel the biggest like
memes are usually the ones that are kind
of like the legends but i feel like even
within the legends
a lot of them you know take their stuff
like very very seriously like you know
the voice for like luffy for example is
like yeah you never see her like meaning
or anything like that yeah yeah you know
the voice for gintoki is like [ __ ]
whatever he's just like playing his
character right he's literally guinta
in real life
it was so um like nerve-wracking because
i don't know because i i've like
i've seen him in like magazines and like
you know i've read his books and like
it was just did you play it cool you i
tried
but um there was like all these other
like voice actors as well who were like
really big right yeah so
it's just i don't know for me it was
really hard to like
act um in front of them yeah yeah yeah
because you know they're like super
super good
yeah you're like you know like you just
came into the industry and you're like
the bottom of the rack
[Laughter]
have you guys ever been star struck by
like anyone i think we've talked about
this probably for me it was like
hiroyuki stamina i think i've already
told the story
yeah have you ever gone that was like a
youtuber
like someone in the same field as you i
don't think so
not yet i think no i don't know like how
after you do it for a while you're just
kind of like
[ __ ] so boring
i just sit inside i would be lying if i
said i wasn't like that with felix the
first time yeah
yeah of course i mean like for me
youtubers i view
youtubers as just like people i want to
hang out with yeah
you know because like we all do the same
thing at the end of the day i feel like
once you get past a certain
like level it or you you kind of get
a certain a certain rank in the
hierarchy you can like all youtubers
kind of like get each other you know
because we all go
we all got to go through like the same
[ __ ]